ES
>> AND I'MLOYG
WEH A CNN IVE.
DENT D MORE
EXR TO SEI V ICE
T N'S VICTORY.
ABTH C PROCESS  TRUMP WAINVOLVEI
PLAYING  MUCH  PUBLIC.BL STATE
SENASAYING PEOPLOU Q, SHOWP MED
EARLY AS TAY THE AGE5.OULD CAS
SE RE. LENI
JOINING US NOW
EMENT CORRESPONDENT
WHITNEY WILD AND CNN CRIMEE REP
POLANCE.HE EXECUTIVES, T
KNOWN.
BU HER T'RE LEARNING ABOUT ANOT
SES TIME
WHAT
MTISOG US
PENTONT
CASE THE DEPARTMENT OFANN
SECURITY TO SEIZ
ADEDENTED AMUP OMP
BIMISTRN
VICTORY.
AC IS UNCLEAR WHTO R WAS
ACTUALLY HAPPENED, BNNT ID OSEI
FOS LIE, B
KECUELEN SOA
CUCCINELLI ALSO TELLN THOSSATIO
SO CUCCINELLI CLEARLY TRYINGO AW
E.
RERTED GIULIANI  REACH
DHS.
NOW THE HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE
IS LOOKINTAFAN, HOE RUULIANI, TA
OBSCURE FIGURE UNT R
SAO IT IS, AGAIN, ANOTHER
THESE PEOPLO SEEM
TO B MUCH HE PERIPHERYEEFF TRY H
SO FROM MY COLLEAGUE
ULH SIBILITY
PRESIDENT BEING HEE ER PRESIDEN.
SOIT
HAD TAPONALRCF BECAUSE THEY HAD
RIPP UP.
W
>> W SS YESTERDAD SOMEE TRUM
UP BRESIDENT TRUMP. SAYING RU DO
SOURCES TOLDE IT IS THE IDENCY.
RECONSTRUCT CU
TE
PURPORTEDLY TO TT  LS
ESNUS,'R
HE THROW AWAY ORS
NATIONAER AS,AINED
GOR TH TRU
ROGERS,COULY DOINTRUMP O >> BY?
KST , IT IS DIFFT W
VEPM
JA6tCO
BECAUSE THERE  AISKEN TO OVERTU
IT GOT SSERIOUS,N EXECUTIVE E .
ITDO
TELL US THGNIFICANCE
RY DEE DRAFT EXIVORDEW. COULDE
E ULTITELY.
WHEN YO A STETOWARD THE COMPLE
CONSPIRACY THAT THE BOUT.
W WHIT,
WAIT DRAFTED AT THCTIOHE FME
WAS IT INSTEAD DRAA
LOWER LEVEL PERSON, AS
JU'S
ABOUT BEFORE THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
THE DRAFT EXECUTIVE REALLYT
THE ALKINGETHING
GIULIANI TO MAKE AKABL THE FORML
. TRUM HIM TE
FOER'ST HERE AND HOW DOES AT --E
THE DOJ'OBE S SO INTERESTING,
BI HAVE BEEN
WATCHING THI
ONS
BY THEORMER PRESIDT.ALY
T VIN BRIN
DIRECTINISRER ABOUT WHAT MIGHT
WHAT IY INTEINCIAL.
IS CREIS IT TI
TIME THAT RUDY GI SE
MAYBBE BREAKING FROM T
FO P POINTING E FINGER AT M.
IFULS GOING TO
BOUTT HAPPEDTELL US ABOUT THOSC
N THIS VESTIGATION.
E SUS.PERSONALVOLVEMG PENCE , IS
LLINCT NOW
ULD HAVE DONE.
YOU NOTED THNEEDS EVIDENCE OOSEN
GETTING PENCE TON THE
RESU VICE PRESIDENT.
WOSHORT'IMONY WITHOUT
PENCBEH TOO THAT?
E WAS THERE.
YOU NEED TNAL
, ANR PRESIDENIF HE
ABOUT WHATE SHOUHAST AS GOOD
IT HIMSES THITO YOU
OUT HOE S GO AHE
ACTION
ING TOGETHS
NSD
UBLIC
I THAT  H T PERSPECVE
DOOU ABOUT THE
DIRECTION THAT THIS IS HEADED IT
I THOU START  SLOWLALLYG STEAM.
EY HAVE BEEN LETTING NTYE TIR U
KNOW IS NAEY
BUT  DHAT WE'RE GOING  A LOTE TH